hey guys know I got a lot of questions
on mooing Daniel what's mooing does it
really work Daniel please make a video
about mooing so in this video that's
what I'm gonna talk about what is mooing
and does it really work I'm gonna give
you guys my honest opinion so let's not
waste any more time let's get to it
[Music]
hey if it's your first time here on my
channel i'm daniel and welcome to d LM
model lifestyle now subscribe and also
click the notification ballot so you
won't miss any of the next videos now
what is mooing no yeah but no that's not
the type of mooing that we're talking
about mooing is a discipline oral
posture technique that improves your
facial structure meaning your jaw line
by altering your tongues
resting position so that it rests on the
roof of your mouth with your teeth close
and together and your lips close and
together as well while breathing through
your nose it also involves chewing and
swallowing your food the right way so
it's a form of myofunctional therapy
that people do because they want a more
defined jawline because I think it will
make them more attractive now the
question is does it really work some of
you guys are thinking huh this is so
stupid
some of you are thinking wow this this
can actually work this might be actually
very very cool some of you are thinking
it works we've tried it out already and
it's awesome
well what does the evidence say well
first check out dr. Mike Moo yes he
surname is moo moo mooing so yeah they
they named the whole mooing thing after
he's surname he's the guy that started
this whole thing well allowed his video
for you in the video description so you
can check him out but the International
Association for face growth gives many
case studies of children as evidence
that it does work it's also a study
published in the Korean journal of
orthodontics in 2004
team that says it works there's also
other research studies published like in
the European Journal of orthodontics in
the AG economy hospital and other
experts show that mewing does work now I
personally believe that more research
should be done on all ages not just
mainly young kids and young adults but
apart from those studies I also did a
little bit more research even in YouTube
a lot of the videos in the comment
sections below I went to go and read and
see hey is there some people who who
experience this themselves and there
were a lot there are many many people do
I believe all of them no because people
I write but it is very hard not to
believe so many people that says it does
work so do I believe that it works well
let me answer you in this way no not if
you're not gonna do it consistently for
a long time but if you are disciplined
and if you do it the right way then yeah
I believe that it can work so why not
try it out for yourself and test it and
see firsthand experience if it works for
you or not
now would I do it well honestly right
now in my life no because there's things
that I want to focus on more and I want
to spend my time on improving other
areas of my life but I have realized
that I have actually always kept my
tongue unconsciously a hundred of my
mouth now did that have an influence on
my jaw line I don't know maybe probably
but I do believe that we should try to
improve ourselves inside Adam in a
healthy balanced way but if we worry too
much about our looks all the time it's
not that healthy so if you're not happy
with your looks then check out this
video and subscribe to my channel and we
will talk soon Cheers
[Music]